first thing that mark said was abolition
of private poverty
and what claude schwab says is someday
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
and today look at the younger generation
you know the tick tock generation coming
up
they're completely
clueless yeah you know that's
when i talk to some of these young
people i don't know what the heck
they're watching or smoking
but there's
they're
they're so they're watching tick tock
yeah
while smoking various other things and
tick tock is a chinese invention
designed to mishmash our brains
are you surprised that so many
corporations went woke and went with
this communist ideology and everything
else because it we know it is hurting
their bottom line to an extent disney
lost something like 61 billion dollars
after fighting desantis uh we know that
all of these companies you know they put
all this product out there for for gay
pride month and nobody buys any of it or
for black pride what month and nobody
buys it but they put it out there they
have to be looking at the numbers at
some point but the ideology seems to
have superseded the whole purpose of
getting into business well that's one
way of fighting back is boycott
you know i mean i i'm very careful who i
buy from
and uh money talks as you know
but
i i feel for the retailers right now is
this
i go shopping and everything's on sale
why because in
because biden took the keystone xl
pipeline destroyed it and then blames
putin for the high price of oil and i
said i'm qualified to speak on this
because as a graduate of the us merge
marine academy at kings point new york
my major was oil i drove tankers for
standard oil i understand oil i
that's and why
you get wait are you getting that good
japanese a5 you must be you must be well
dave i hate to admit this but
i've always wanted to be a japanese
breeding bowl but i never got to be
there
they live a good life
you think about it man all you do is as
a japanese breeding ball you sit there
and you have sex all day
my god that's it that sounds like
genghis khan to me i want to do that
ah you're doing all right you're doing
all right i invest in waiku breeding
bowls
and they get you get paid for the semen
and the semen then goes into the cows i
own the cows also then i own the
offspring
that's cap
is this all in japan
is this all in japan it's in wyoming
oh it's in wyoming so you can breed
using
oh oh of course you can grow wagyu just
not not specific japanese wagyu right
that has to be from japan i don't know
all the specifics
it's called a brand
yeah and why waiku
because rich guys eat waiku
poor people eat hamburger
okay
or cat
food look
we'll be get we'll be good to doing mass
cat food for everybody soon enough yeah
i'm unapologetically a capitalist but i
want my freedom don't you touch my
freedoms
you know you want to eat hamburger knock
yourself out you want to eat cat food
knock yourself out
this uh this concept where no one will
own anything which seems to be one of
the other things they're talking about
right now this must make your blood boil
well that's that guy what's his name uh
schwab
klaus schwab i don't know who that
character is but my god
how can it that's pure marx
first thing that marx said was abolition
of private property and what claus
schwab says is someday you'll own
nothing and you'll be happy
and today look at the younger generation
you know the tick tock generation coming
up
they're completely clueless
yeah you know that's
when i talk to some of these young
people i don't know what the heck
they're watching or smoking
but there's
they're
they're so they're watching tick tock
yeah
while smoking various other things and
tick tock is a chinese invention
designed to mishmash our brains
yeah
literally
literally so that's why i say this
little iphone here is the most powerful
tool ever created
we've got to be careful with it
so i'm pumping financial education
through it
but you can pump other things through it
too
so we need to fight back by being
selective on what we study what we eat
who we support who we buy from
because money does talk like it or not
i like it i have no problem with it uh
before we started the show i was talking
about the five g's with my guys can we
go through the five g's
of course i love the 5gs
i know i know take it away number one is
gold
gold is god's it's still worth something
gold is god's money it was placed here
with silver
when earth was formed
you know people say it's 5 000 years old
no it's as old as the earth gold and
silver so i own lots of gold and silver
i own a gold mine i just took a company
public last week new york stock exchange
the richest gold mine in the world
it's in
utah 140 year old mine we applied new
technology to it
and we found the richest veins in the
world
wow so gold is one
grub
waiku cattle
you can eat hamburger or cat food i'd
rather have waiku
i mean
grub
ground real estate
let's take is debt financing
the reason i invest in real estate as
most people know this appreciation
depreciation amortization
all of those are tax dodges
so i so if i make a million dollars in
the in the income column
i need a bill i need to i need 5 million
in debt in the liability column
so by taking 1 million to 5 million
i step up my basis to 6 million i
depreciate i pay no tax
that's why
and that that basically is what hillary
was angry at trump over because he knew
how to do it yeah because she's not
she's a thief
right she just takes other people's
money for the non-profit she wants to
attack
but you know trump does it legally you
know she did that uranium one deal with
her husband
bill
so they steal
you know it's horrible so where was i
ground
gasoline
oil
and then the third one guns fourth fifth
one is guns
so i i'm fully armed all the time you
know i was i was just
i was just with mr shapiro he's armed
it's sad that we we're we have to be
this way
but i'm also marines i carry full
automatics
my rate of fire i step up the rate of
fire at my machine guns from about 700
rounds a minute to a thousand rounds per
minute
when i buy when i buy ammunition to buy
by the case i buy by the pallet load
you're not messing around man no i'm
like you know al pacino and scarface
that's me my wife says that's you isn't
it he's up there going like this with
his guns going [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you that's me don't leave the uh don't
leave the fence open at the end
that's the key to the whole thing every
time i leave my house i make sure the
gate closes behind me yeah it's really
sad isn't it
it used to be you could trust everybody
now it's
anyway it's that's why i wrote rich dad
poor dead that's why i create the cash
flow game what the hand does the mind
remembers
and that's why i support people like
desantis and trump
because they're capitalists
we have to support capitalists if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell